Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob. And today I want to try something a little bit different, uh,
with QI and black,
having recently come out and you guys going absolutely nuts over that video.
I thought it'd be a good time to go over pretty much all the symbionts in the
Marvel universe, as well as highlight some of the hosts of those symbionts.
And when figuring out the best way to do this, we basically have two options.
We can go in the chronological order based on the date of their first
appearance, or we can go in chronological order based on where,
in the timeline of the Marvel universe they appeared.
And I think the second option will make the most sense as we progress throughout
the symbionts. And so that's what we're going to do.
That means that we need to start with the very beginning of the history of the
symbionts and because that history has been retcon relatively recently,
that means we're going to go with one of the most recent characters to be
introduced. No, the God of the symbionts. So, uh, for the,
all the guys who are a little bit behind here,
Knoll was created by Donnie Cates and Ryan Stegman. And first appeared in venom,
number three in 2008 with his origin being revealed in the very next issue.
So Knoll is older than the Marvel universe itself existing in a dormant state
until he was awakened by the Celestials.
When they began creating the current iteration of the Marvel universe.
Now anchor that the Celestials were filling the void that he ruled Knoll creates
all black, the Necro sword and slays one of the Celestials with it,
a crime for which he's banished back to the void. Now,
no uses this opportunity to grow more formidable strengthening the all-black
sword in a Ford that was made from the head of the dead celestial, all black,
we would later learn what the prototype of the race that would become the
symbionts as we know them and the fire of the forge and the sound of nose hammer
would instill in all future symbionts vulnerabilities in both fire and sound.
Now, no goes on a murderous rampage across the universe,
destroying billions of solar systems in the process until he stopped by Gore,
the God butcher who defeats Knoll and takes all black from him.
Now in the century, following his defeat,
no figured out that he could actually bond his living of abyss with lesser
creatures and control them across galaxies,
thereby creating the first true symbionts. Now in terms of power, no,
definitely lives up to his name as God of the symbionts because he's God like in
his power,
his primary ability is that he can create weapons and other symbionts using the
living a bisque. Not only is he capable of creating literal armies of symbionts,
but he can also control them through a telepathic link that he shares with them.
In addition to this,
he's immortal and possess a super human strength and durability to the point of
being practically in vulnerable. And the thing about nose powers is this.
I would wager that we haven't even come close to seeing the limits of what he
can do. I mean,
and the most recent issue we saw him in snare Celestials into his bidding and
that's just the tip of the iceberg.
And so I imagine that we're probably going to see null display some ridiculous
abilities that we didn't even know that he had. Now,
one of the first symbionts that no created was the Grendel,
which was also created by Donnie Cates and Ryan Stegman.
And first appeared in venom. Number four.
Now Grindle was one of several symbionts that took the form of a dragon and it
was while piloting the Grendel Symbion that no first learned of earth now was
Grindle attacked a village. The villagers cried out for their hero Bay Wolf,
but were instead answered by Thor.
Now four strikes Grindle with a bolt of lightning,
which severs Knowles control over his symbionts and his vulnerability to
electricity. What continue to be a trait of symbionts long into the future.
The resulting symbions began seeking out new hosts.
We producing and rebelling against nil,
which is how the race of symbionts created by Knoll became the Clint heart,
which we learn. Is there a racist word for cage and imprison their deity?
Now the Grendel symbiont possesses, superhuman strength, stamina,
and durability, which are powers that are common to symbionts,
but Grendel's powers are of a much higher scale than most symbionts due to him
having such a close connection with its creator note. Now,
the Grinell Symbion is also able to generate other symbionts and is also able to
reanimate corpses by bonding them to its offspring. Of course,
the most popular Simeon and the one introduced to the Marvel universe is venom.
The version of venom most are familiar with was created by David Michelina and
Todd McFarland. And first appeared in the amazing Spiderman number 319 88,
but his origins in the Marvel universe go back much further than that.
The Symbion that would become known as venom was part of the 998th generation of
Symbion offspring and was cast out from the rest of the symbiotic for being
mentally insane before being obtained by the CRE who hoped to harness its
shape-shifting abilities and their war with the scrolls. Now,
the Symbian was bonded to a CRE warrior named hell cart,
but was eventually separated from him and returned to the Cree home world before
somehow making its way to battle world,
which leads us to the symbionts original origin story as told in secret Wars
number eight by Jim shooter and Mike Zack. Now in that issue of secret Wars,
which I have a whole story covered,
you can find the link to it down in the description in the ensuing chaos
Spider-Man's costume gets ripped up,
but luckily the heroes find a machine that can create any clothing that they
want Spiderman, however,
chooses the wrong machine and is covered by a black goop that becomes his new
costume,
kind of a fun fact here and Deadpool secret secret war Marvel actually changed
that. So the Deadpool was on battle world, which we didn't know about,
and he actually directed Spider-Man to the machine itself,
not realizing that it actually had a venom Simeon in it.
And that's how Peter Parker basically became new venom,
but it's kind of a small, fun,
little retcon the story's really good if you guys ever get a chance,
it's a really, really, really fun story,
but regardless Spider-Man wears this costume for awhile,
but then he begins to realize that it was trying to bond to him permanently.
And so he leaves it with the fantastic four who believe that they have the
Symbian contained.
Of course they don't and the semi escapes and bonds to Peter once again,
but Parker still rejected it by exploiting its weakness to Sonics and ringing
church bells to drive it away. Now,
a disgrace reporter named Eddie Brock would then wonder into the church seeking
some sense of direction in his life.
The discarded venom Symbion could tell that Eddie harbored hatred for Peter
Parker, who he blamed for his professional downfall.
So the symbiont bonded with Eddie,
turning him into venom and brought in the Simeon,
joined together in their common mission to get revenge on Peter Parker.
Now Venom's powers include superhuman strength and durability as well as
shape-shifting including the ability to disguise itself by replicating the
appearance of normal street clothes. Now, because it's bonded with Spiderman,
the venom Symbion has inherited super powers such as the ability to produce and
swing from webs and is also immune to Peter Parker's spider sense,
but Eddie is not the last host of the venom Symbian. And in fact,
the Simeon has bonded with several other individuals.
And I guess I'm already going out of order here in terms of chronology,
but since these are all hosts of the venom Simeon,
I figured we go ahead and discuss them all here. Anyway,
it kind of makes the most sense.
So after the venom Symbion was separated from Eddie,
it approached another of Spider-Man's perennial foes, the scorpion Matt Gargan.
And so what happens is that Norman Osborn had been imprisoned and needed
Spiderman to break him out, which of course Spiderman would never do,
except that under Norman Osborn's orders,
scorpion a kidnapped aunt may and would only free her if Spider-Man helped break
Norman out of jail, which makes sense.
Now during the conversation where Matt explains this arrangement to Peter,
Peter makes the remark that scorpion will always be a B-list villain
specifically saying it's not like your venom, but when Matt goes home,
the venom Symbion is waiting for him and offers to bond with him,
telling him that on his own, he'll always be a joke,
but if he bonds with a Symbian, no one will ever laugh at him. Again,
obviously scorpion takes him up on this offer, or you wouldn't be in this video.
And he becomes venom,
which granted him all the same powers that Eddie Brock had had his venom until
the Simeon was removed from Gargan after he was arrested for his antics as one
of the dark Avengers during the dark brain story.
Now another of Venom's notable hosts was flashed Thompson,
a sometimes rival and sometimes friend of Peter Parker who lost his legs in a
heroic sacrifice during the Iraq war.
Now with the U S government in possession of the venom Simeon at the time,
and the amazing Spiderman number 654 by Dan Slott,
they approach flash about participating in project rebirth 2.0 now why do they
call it that? Because the program that turned Steve Rogers into captain America,
what's called project rebirth.
And the Cardinal rule of Marvel comics is that every organization without
exception,
wants to replicate the success of that original program and create their own
super soldier.
Now flash agrees and is bonded with the Symbion turning him into agent venom,
which rents him all the powers of his favorite hero Spiderman as well as venom
shape-shifting abilities and a specific significance to flash the venom semi.
It would also allow him to walk again and he would remain bonded to the venom.
Symbion from 2011, up until 2016.
So a pretty long time by modern comic standards.
Something else to kind of note here, depending on who you talk to.
A lot of people actually liked agent venom more than they like Eddie Brock
venom. He was hugely popular when he first came out, people loved him.
People love the story of Asian venom. I feel like we should cover it.
Let me know down in the comments section,
if you guys want me to cover agent venom,
I don't know if you guys want me to or not.
I feel like it'd be kind of interesting,
but before we get into the offspring of the venom Simeon,
something that I do want to point out here is that there are several more hosts
of the venom Simeon over the years in both the main mobile continuity and even
in alternative realities, for example, in the old man Logan universe,
which basically imagines the Marvel universe as a desolate post-apocalyptic
wasteland,
we see the venom Symbion had actually bonded to a literal T-Rex in Wolverine
number 69 by Mark Miller and Steve McNiven.
Now this version seems to basically be identical to the Symbion of the six one
six universe. So we can assume that this venomous Rex venom venom source Rex,
this, I liked venomous Rex, uh, just has the normal venom powers and abilities,
uh, on earth 65,
the numerical designation of the universe where Gwen Stacy became Spidergwen.
There is a version of venom that was created by a scientist named Elsa Brock in
an attempt to find a cure for the lizard formula that had turned that universe
as Peter Parker into the lizard.
A first appearing inspired when number 19 by Jason Latour and Robbie Rodriguez,
the venom of earth, 65 is not an alien Symbion,
but as artificially created by a reaction between the radioactive spider
isotopes that gave Gwen her powers and the lizard formula.
Now Gwen would later bond with the Symbion to become Wynnum and spider when
number 24,
the venom to be at Grant's it's where all the powers that spider Gwen had,
which are essentially the same as the Spiderman of earth six one six,
but it also must have a compatible host as it will kill incompatible ones
through the radiation from the spider isotopes. Furthermore,
the Symbion makes its way are subject to overly aggressive behavior by removing
their inhibitions and amplifying their emotions.
And so this version of the Symbion also retains the weaknesses to heat Sonics of
the main universe venom. Now moving on to the offspring of venom,
the first and most prominent is of course carnage,
which was created by David McEleney and Mark Bagley.
And first appeared in amazing Spider-Man number three 61 and 1992.
Now the car December, it was created when Eddie Brock,
who is bonded with the venom Simeon at the time,
escape from prison and unbeknownst to Eddie left an offspring behind that would
bond with a cellmate. I'm a nickel serial killer named Cleese Cassidy.
Now Cassidy would be the most frequent host of the Cornett Symbion whose
abilities differ significantly from the venom symbiotic,
because carnage was born into an environment alien to its species,
the environment of earth. And so the corn of had strength surpasses that event,
and it also possesses advanced shape-shifting abilities,
allowing us host to turn appendages into weapons and can even fire projectile
weapons made of the Symbion itself.
This semi gets tendrils can implant thoughts in the minds of others.
It can also relay information.
It perceives from any direction to its host instantaneously the CMBA grants,
its hosts, a regenerative healing factor,
and like venom is undetectable by Peter Parker spider sense,
and it's highly adaptive to its environment. For example,
evolving to allow its host to breathe in space.
Now when the codex or the genetic imprint of the carnage Symbion reacted with
the Grendel, Symbion when it reanimated Cletus Cassidy's corpse,
the result was a far more powerful entity than carnage had ever been before.
And it also gained the ability to create brain worms,
which you can use to infect others and turn them into copies of carnage.
Now in the 1993 mini series venom lethal protector by David McEleney,
Mark Bagley and Ron Lim. We see the introduction of five more symbionts scream,
riot, phage, Lasher, and agony.
Now the story here centers around a group called the life foundation dedicated
to ensuring the survival of the country's wealthiest citizens in the event of an
apocalypse type event. Now, when venom interferes with one of their plans,
they extract part of the venom Symbion and choose five of the life foundation
security guards.
These five symbions seem to have basically the same powers as venom,
but also seemed to be slightly less powerful.
I eventually screamed murders her four siblings,
but only the host while the other symbionts are taken to the volt super prison
and merged into one Symbion known as hybrid and venom along, came a spider.
Number one by Larry Hama and Joe Saint here.
Now the symbionts were subjected to extremely painful experiments.
And once volt guard, Scott Washington discovers this,
he releases them from their confinement and all for bond with them.
Now due to the experimentation by the government,
these symbionts gained some unique abilities such as heightened senses.
In the case of phage Lasher's ability to bond with animals,
riots ability to move faster than the naked eye can detect and agony his ability
to increase its host musculature and spit acid.
And so when Scott Washington became hybrid,
he gained all of these powers as well as the standard Symbian powers.
But venom is not the only Symbion to produce offspring.
It's carnage has produced some itself. The first of which is toxin.
So toxin was created by Peter Milligan and Clayton crane.
And first appeared in venom carnage, number two in 2004.
Then when carnage found out that he was about to reproduce,
he began fostering a deep seated hatred for his eventual offspring fearing that
it may become more powerful than himself. And so he decides to kill it.
As soon as it's born. Now, venom tries to talk him out of this.
Of course it doesn't work because carnage is insane.
So venom tries to protect the new Symbion as he also fears that it will be the
Symbion that may become unstable due to being the 1000 generation of their race
and sort of hide the Symbion from venom carnage gives birth to it and then bonds
it with the New York city police officer named Patrick Mulligan and attempts to
kill both of them. But of course he stopped by venom. Now,
once venom realizes how strong the toxin symbiont will become,
he decides carnage is ride and helps them try to kill it.
But toxin is aided in battle by Spiderman when they defeat venom and carnage.
Now toxin has all the venom and carnage abilities and is physically stronger
than either of them and also possesses,
inability to track any other individual and expansion of the ability that most
symbionts have to track other symbionts or their hosts.
Now the next Simeon that we're introduced to is actually not a true Symbion,
but it's part of a race known as the barriers,
which are genetically similar offshoot to the Clint har race. Now, Trent,
who is an agent of shield is approached by a symbiotic called payback that had
previously bonded to his father.
The payback semi had deferred from the venom Simeon and his progeny and a
variety of ways.
First it fed off the bliss of its host and was more of an entity made of energy
and set of organic matter.
In addition to enhanced physical attributes and a healing factor,
the payback Symbion allows its host to fly and project electromagnetic energy.
Of course being pure energy.
The payback Symbion has a vulnerability to water and coming into contact with
water. What result in Occidental expulsions of electricity? Next up,
we have antivenom created by Dan Slott and John Romita Jr.
And making his debut and amazing Spider-Man number 569 and 2008.
Now Eddie rock is working at a soup kitchen run by Martin Lee.
The supervillain known as Mr. Negative leak.
Here's Eddie of his cancer using his ability to control light force energy.
And shortly thereafter,
Eddie is attacked by Matt Gargan who was bonded to venom at the time.
The venom Symbion tries to rebond with Eddie,
but touching Eddie's skin harms venom.
And part of the Symbion merge with the antibodies created by the light force
energy to create a Holy new symbiont known as antivenom.
Now the antivenom Symbion has all the abilities of venom,
but does not possess its weaknesses to sound and fire.
The Simeon is able to heal others from a variety of afflictions through its
ability to produce antibodies, but using this ability drains antivenoms powers,
furthermore antivenom does display a weakness to dark force energy,
which is the dark counterpart to the light force energy that led to its
creation. Now this brings us to a weird one.
The mutant Symbion known as Zendesk's ZX is literally
zzz X, X. I don't know how to pronounce that XYX XYX.
I have no idea what is going to call it Z credit by Chris yaasss and Dustin
Weaver, Z first you're at an X-Men King breaker. Number two in 2009.
Now Z was a symbiont discovered by the sheer empire,
unlike any they had ever seen before,
as it actually fed on the brains of its host.
Now Zee was locked away for years as one of the five most dangerous criminals
the CR had ever encountered.
But Volkan the brother of Scott and Alex Summers chosen to be part of his
Imperial guard and bonded him to a sheer soldier before bonding to the star
jammer, Roz, a long knife,
and eventually the cancer vers version of Charles Xavier,
which was basically just a giant brain for CZI to feed on is really all.
It was other than the bit about eating the brains of its host,
Z seems to have pretty much the same powers as other symbionts.
Then we have the second offspring of carnage, which is known as SCORM,
which was created by zip Wells and Clayton crane at first appeared in corners,
number four in 2011. And so at this point,
carnage was ripped in half by the century and left to float through the
endlessness of space,
but it actually survived the experience and returned to earth.
Now a man named Michael Hall,
discovers carnage and tries to use it to create artificial limbs.
But when a doctor named tennis knees loses his arm,
she gets one of these prosthetics to replace it. And as you may have guessed,
the results are disastrous as she's unable to control the Symbion,
which killed several people as it bonds to her.
Then when the cart Symbion finds cleanness, Cassidy, it leased Hanis,
but leaves behind an offspring that bonds with Tannis turning her into scorn,
a hybrid Symbian cyborg.
Now the main distinction between scoring and other symbionts is that she can
bond herself to technology due to her techno organic physiology.
She's also able to communicate with and control various types of technology and
can change yourself into any form of technology that she comes into contact
with. Now, carnage is offspring do not stop there. However, as during jelly,
Conway's run on carnage in 2016,
an FBI agent named Claire Dixon is captured by coronation and use in a ritual
whereby he tries to bolster his power, using a book called the dark hole.
The result is that Claire is turned into a symbiont known as res who seems to
have no powers beyond those common, to all symbionts. And finally,
we come to sleeper. Now sleeper was created by Mike Costa and Mark Bagley.
And first appeared in venom number 165 in 2018.
The final issue of venom before the current Donnie Kate's run began.
Now Claire Dixon, who we just discussed was thought to be dead,
but as it turns out due to her exposure to the dark hole,
she couldn't actually die. Anyway,
she captures Eddie Brock and tells him that the venom Symbion is about to give
birth Eddie escapes and finds a doctor to help deliver the spot a process that's
difficult for the venom Symbion and despite an attempt by scorpion to steal the
spawn as it was born,
it successfully delivered and kept in the care of Al CAMACS.
Now this offspring would become known as sleeper and was stolen by Telecar the
first host of venom after the venom, Simeon refused to bond with him once more.
And so before Telecar could bond with sleeper, the symbiont bonded with Eddie,
not sleeper would later Labatt,
automize Telecar and use his body to explore space where he learned about Knoll
and came back to earth to protect Eddie and his son Dylan. No,
in addition to the normal Symbian powers,
sleeper has displayed an ability to become invisible and to produce a variety of
chemicals and pheromones to produce a wide variety of effects,
including manipulating the thoughts and emotions of others.
And so that's pretty much the most major symbionts in the Marvel universe.
I'm not going to say all because there may have been a couple that slipped
through the cracks. I don't think they are. I think for the most part,
we pretty much caught them all up,
but I'm sure you'll let me know in the comments, if I did forget a few.
So with that being said, if you guys are new here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob port.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later. Pers.
[Inaudible].